[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
adam lefko
tuesday nba on tnt host and uh host of
the
lefko show on bleacher report just back
from his honeymoon
who gets married during the nba season
when they cover the nba
is that a real question for me yes it is
that's a real guy you went around on me
well
well i was supposed to get married last
year dan and then this covet thing
happened so it was perfectly
scheduled and i didn't know the schedule
was gonna happen like this
also ernie's got it
you know they come you're looking at me
i'm not working anyway you think ernie's
getting off that desk
are you kidding me this is what ernie
lives for er
ernie is let me tell you they come at a
commercial
and he gets to hit him with the you know
25 of the last 27 times that the bucks
have been trailing after two games they
come on man he's got the stats ready i'm
not taking his time
i want to watch ernie anyway okay are
you still married i am honeymoon was
amazing went to hawaii
uh and the best thing is the time
difference hey babe
i think yeah let's take that two o'clock
nap perfect
game starts at three it was it was
amazing
um all right where do you want to start
with uh
the network you were just where you just
were buttonholzer what the heck is he
doing
i mean that dude did that can you
imagine the pressure on him right now
heading back to milwaukee down 2-0 when
everyone couldn't believe that they
kept him anyway it's more of the same
dan and that's what's incredible to me
they were this season
they allowed the most threes per game of
any team in the nba
second worst three-point percentage in
terms of allowed
this is what they've done every single
year and yet
we are not everybody we all looked at
each other and said are we gonna do this
again
are we gonna go to the playoffs and
we're gonna let teams hit threes
and giannis and explicitly inexplicably
is gonna be at the top of the three
and they're gonna create a wall and
we're gonna go man chris middleton
really good nba player in the regular
season kind of a three
when it comes to the playoffs we're
gonna do this again
i just don't understand i'm sitting
there i'm texting with candace parker
last night
and i'm going didn't you say all season
long that they were running giannis on
the block
and that it opened up everything else
because of his ability to pass
and it gets him closer to the basket and
she's like i don't get it
she's like it's like it's like they
didn't work on any of this
all year and and i i just it's it's
crazy to me man because
we're going to blame giannis and he's
going to he's going to get this one more
pass because if it doesn't work out
they're going to get rid of buttonholes
or then they're going to go
maybe it's the coach i just how much
more of this kid's prime can we waste
and if it's if it's him then that's an
issue too yeah well i was just going to
ask you
is this coaching or is it personnel
i i i think game three we're gonna learn
a lot they need to play
through true holiday on offense and they
need to figure out a way to slow this
down because they're going up against
the nets team
that doesn't even have jeff green let
alone james harden
and like i i know it's an unstoppable
force
but the big storyline that i saw kind of
developing last night was oh we are
getting
the devin booker heroes journey
where he becomes the young padawan
that goes on to face the evil nets
in the finals uh led by obi-wan
kenobi in chris paul like you could just
see
the nba storyline being developed last
night but
yeah in terms of the bucks man play
through true holiday get giannis on the
block
stop allowing all these threes and do
something i'm like poking them with a
stick on the ground
right now is there a better
starting five when they start than the
nets
when you think about offensive
efficiency in nba history
i just i how quickly we forget those
warriors teams
i don't know i just remember sitting
there when clay had that game fixed
against the thunder
where it didn't seem like the ball ever
touched the ground
you know there's a difference in style
of this offense i
i get amazed at the individual talents
when kyrie takes someone off the dribble
it's a monday
when kevin durant just steps back and
shoots and there's nothing you can do
it's just unstoppable it's like thanos
and then when you watch james harden
you know it's it's maybe the greatest
101 player ever but the warriors the
ball never touched the ground
you know it was the passing it was the
efficiency it was
it was this gravitational force that was
stephen curry so
uh i think that one i mean look i don't
know the numbers on it but
it felt more efficient just because it
felt more artistic this feels more
like singular attacking
yeah i would agree with you what golden
state did and how they did it
uh to me i had not seen before you know
you had the celtics with the big three
with bird mchale and parish but
offensive efficiency wasn't close to
this even if you threw an ange and dj
bill walton off the bench uh you know
we've seen the 76ers with dr
j they had it or they had a lot of
talent at every position there
low cheeks yeah daryl dawkins everybody
yeah
andrew tony yeah and then you throw in
the showtime lakers
if you have magic kareem and
uh worthy mean there there have been
there have been teams that rival this
um what about the miami heat with bosch
wade and lebron
see that it didn't feel as offensively
impressive as these teams do like that
felt more as like a complete
dominant team performance because lebron
and wade had that mind
meld going on and then chris bosh was
always in the right spot defensively
and i do it like when i think of that oh
man ray allen out there as well who will
go down as one of the greatest shooters
of all time
this this though it feel because lebron
offense isn't as artistic as these guys
it is brute force whereas durant they
just did an incredible article i think
it was in the new york times where it
talked about
how effortless his motion it is and when
james naismith invented the game
his fourth rule may have been trust me
when you see kevin durant this is how
it's supposed to be played
um these guys just it feels more
artistic
whereas lebron and even my guy wade
it was just a lot more physical and
spacing and putting a guy on your hip
can the nets win a title without harden
shoot after last night it kind of makes
you think so i i think that
the stars are aligning in terms of the
competition uh
my dummy head just made a bet with a
friend that the sixers are going to come
back and beat the hawks and i don't even
feel confident about that
uh but if mb with his knee with mb going
down i always looked at embiid
as the one force in the east that if
he's able to do his
40 15 and whatever uh he could be that
and it doesn't seem like he's going to
be
i i know we're getting all hopped up on
the hawks but uh it's a games it's kind
of a games one fool's goal i still think
they're great and trey young has figured
it out
and in the west uh okay you got the suns
i look kawhi went terminator mode
uh and and i'm texting with wade and
he's just going out you know when he
does that you just sit back and go what
do we do because you can't stop it
um and i i just don't see any other team
and it may be utah but no i i think the
next can win without harden i think
it'll be
a lot more dominant with him but after
last night i think all my fears kind of
went away
are you all in on the clippers no
are you kidding are you no no i
it's i i can't guarantee what i'm gonna
get any night
because now are you all in on the
clippers
if you get kawhi game six and game seven
against the mavericks
every game
yeah i i guess a bit but see i don't i
i'm not worried about kawhi he had one
bad game in the series
it's the other guys that i just remember
beverly oh
yeah he'll be great against luca and uh
play off rondo and i go
okay yeah i mean it comes down to
if paul george is consistently good and
cool
is kawhi all right but i think utah is a
better team i
i i we don't want to embrace utah uh
because we go well they don't really
have stars there
uh but they play good team defense and
they shoot the three
and that feels like that's you know a
pretty good formula to advance here
hey dan you know how this this whole
year with russell westbrook everyone was
debating the meaningfulness of a triple
double i would like to draw up the
meaningfulness
of a regular season 50 40 90.
because i think it's time we talk about
it 50 from the field 40
from 3 90 from three point new three
guys that have
that were either at that mark surpassed
it or always around it
tobias harris paul george and chris
middleton
all three of them were either going to
the all-star game or getting really
close because of those numbers
and all three of those guys those
numbers become meaningless when the
playoffs start
meaningless all three of those guys i'm
going okay tobias you got 180 million
dollars
paul george i mean you you complain that
the rest don't treat you like a
superstar and you say that you are
and chris middleton i mean here we are
talking about he's a modern day
scorer and all that and then when the
playoffs start i don't see him
and so 50 40 90 is supposed to be this
all-time
test because steve nash did it and steph
curry did it
but these guys from the playoffs start
absolutely no show and and look
the the the stories can still be written
differently but
i just all three of those guys need to
be great for their teams to win and i
just can't bet on that
more likely to play for a championship
first
the greek freak or luca wow
i think that the the main reason i'm
going to say the greek freak
is because i don't know how the
mavericks are going to get rid of that
porzingis contract
and until they do i don't know what they
do
he's making over 30 million for the next
three seasons
and i i thought last night i went wow
how great would it be if cuban could
dump that contract
and then make a run at kauai after the
season when he's a free agent
could you imagine luca and kawhi next to
each other
and then i went wait who are the teams
that are even built to take on that
salary
and there's two right now that have over
30 million in cap space
the spurs and the knicks and there's no
reason mr taking porzingis
and i thought is there any way that this
spurs franchise with their love of
foreign-born players would fall in love
with the
latvian freak named porzingis and think
we could be the ones to turn it around
and then i smacked myself in the face
and went
there is no player left san antonio than
kristaps porzingis
who after a season which he does nothing
and he sat on the bench for most of it
goes out there and complains that he is
not treated
like a number two so i until they get
rid of that contract i'm gonna go greek
freak because
at least i know that they may get a new
coach that can turn it around
um but yeah with porzingis contract i
just can't bet on luca right now
you still married man it's good
dan i like it the only thing is i got my
ring is too small i had a lot of pizza
last night and now i can't get it off
but she likes well you're not supposed
to take it off that's what she keeps
saying but like you know i want to play
with it you know i want to i want to act
like i'm in the matrix or something
you got any marital advice for me
[Laughter]
it's too late for that
just be a good listener remember
everything she says
just just concentrate on everything
because she'll
probably at some point going are you are
you even listening to me
and and you want to i just want to ask
the dan that's really quick
shout out to frizzy uh i just want to
ask them every time i ask dan for advice
he just tells me to listen
you know hey how do i do a really good
job hosting nba on tnt just listen
don't talk hey how do i have a good
marriage just listen does he listen to
you guys
or does he just talk the entire time
because does this man follow what he
preaches i'm just seeing a trend here
uh does anybody want to be a
spokesperson for the dance yeah when you
think dan's not listening
four months later he'll be remember that
thing you said on tuesday in may and
you're like oh man
okay i'm listening i'm listening lefko
yes i love that adam one time uh about
13 years ago i made a joke about how
dan's not a good singer and he's never
forgotten that so
i can speak i love to sing here in the
studio during commercial breaks and
and you know i'll just start singing
i'll see seton and then i'll go yeah i
know i can't sing and then i just keep
walking and still singing
do you sing or do you croon because i
feel like you're much more of a crooner
i'm a lounge singer
bobby goulet yeah yeah yeah i'm bringing
it
you snap when you sing too don't you a
little bit
yeah oh man yeah i think i'm sort of
uh like barry white you know i've i i
i'm very extremely white
and when i bring the voice down like
this
the brother barry white i mean that's
when you start to melt
some hearts oh god i got i got
i just had to get a little steamy had to
take a paper towel
oh don't let your wife hear this
you're right yeah uh putting you on mute
yeah hey great to talk to you again
congratulations talking to you
thank you pal i'm going to take this i'm
going to take the over on the wedding
and and the uh marriage i'm going to
take the over okay
yeah see i knew i loved you i knew i was
going to thank you
the over's only five and a half so i'm
good
five and a half decades lefko my
man that's how you turn it around i love
it
thank you bud that's uh adam lefkow
tuesday
nba on tnt host lefko show on bleacher
report